[Musique]
covin nineteen cambi caractèrise has et
pandemic
[Musique]
je vais est clair si vous êtes à
l'étranger
il est temps de rentrer chez vous covert
night in constitue un des joueurs
majeurs au projet montréal québec sur
pause
s'il vous plaît vous restez à la maison
[Musique]
et c'est encore du côté des résidences
pour personnes âgées que la situation
est nettement la plus préoccupante voit
des gens qui ont été barrés dans leur
chambre et ont même pas accès à une
salle de bain si j'ai jamais vu ça c'est
ce que virus de même on n'est jamais sûr
non plus long mais
ils ont perdu le contrôle et on
travaillait à envier au québec y
contribuer à bâtir la société pis autres
entraîneurs en train de mourir tout seul
pour niveau des dan moussa avait échangé
plus de travail c'est le chef cuisinier
vit des moments difficiles et 50% dans
une clientèle que qu'on n'avait pas
avant mais qu'on voit des nouveaux
usages qui sont jamais fumé
les chorales excellent pour le moral
justement ces lots à la longue ouais
comme je dis c'est pour les codes pour
l'épreuve que pour les étudiants c'est
la même chose c'est juste c'est l'eau
je suis tellement brisé je les dis que
papa était au ciel
après le speed très rapidement on compte
pouvoir vacciner la totalité de la
population américaine vers le mois de
mai ou juin à saint fons vaccin le
spoutnik canton tout premier satellite
la russie n'a jamais caché son jeu le
pari est énorme
le résultat est payant je soutenais qui
est en orbite plus populaires à
l'étranger qu'ici même en russie
c'est une grande journée historique pour
le québec
on devrait être capable de vacciner
jusqu'à plus de 50000 personnes d'ici le
4 janvier c'était non seulement la façon
de tourner la page sur une année
difficile beaucoup de résidents ça donne
l'espoir que on peut se reprendre vie
[Musique]
l'expert
on va avoir un couvre-feu au québec le
message c'est on reste chez soi un
espèce de traitement show faut être
capable de faire des mesures qui
ensemble ont continué la probabilité de
rassemblement
je comprends pourquoi on en arrive dans
samantha mentalement moi j'ai une
question de deux suivent
[Musique]
en délestant qu on se met la tête dans
le sable est un vrai problème vient du
monde avec des cancers guérissable qui
ne seront pas guéri j'ai dit pour la
tente c'est quoi il pense même plus
ces quatre tout ce qui l'est plus droit
de prose
c'est complètement déstabilisant penser
qu'on est rendu le thé en 2021 que vous
êtes retrouvé la maladie c'est le 25
décembre que j'ai pris de la l'ambulance
pour m'enlever ce particulier je ne sais
pas exactement combien de temps je
passais dans le coma puis je m'ennuie ma
femme mes enfants
c'est très inquiétant ce nouveau variant
les bars y ont été associés à des
explosions donc divers milieux vous
éviter que ces souches ne devienne et
souche dominante
parce que ce que ça veut dire c'est que
il va y avoir plus de coop plus
rapidement la population en général vont
commencer à vacciner vacciner c'est
gagner aux travailleurs de la santé qui
participent aux efforts de vaccination
je veux vous dire merci et des millions
de doses qui s'en viennent
alors continuons de travailler tous
ensemble pour vacciner les canadiens le
plus rapidement aussi
aujourd'hui québec se souviennent de
toutes ces personnes qui sont parties
tout roule
ils ne sont plus avec nous mais il reste
dans notre mémoire nous nous
souviendrons d'eux